Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday. It's take your brother to work day.
Oh look!
There you are! Right in the entryway.
So you walk in, first thing you see is the crash course posters
and some foreign editions of The Fault In Our Stars.
And then you see Danica's Mac
with it's wiggly eyes
and Danica herself, hi Danica
[Danica]: Hello
This area is for the visitors we don't have.
Danica works on Crash Course.
She does all those chalkboard drawings that are so excellent
and also the Mental Floss set.
Then you come to our printer room where Wil Wheaton and Felicia Day
have the place of honor,
and then you spin around and look, oh, it's Meredith!
Who doesn't want to be on TV today.
Meredith writes for Mental Floss,
but more importantly,
is the CEO of the Swindon Town Swoodilypoopers.
And then we come to my office.
Oh hi, there Buster, scared of sheep.
This is my couch.
This is the lazy boy where I've written at least parts of every single one of my books
And this is the treadmill desk where I have taken
360 whole steps today.
Oh, and what?
A signed Pelé jersey that says
"To J. Green, DFTBA, good luck, Pelé."
Whaaat?
This is the television where the Swindon Town Swoodilypoopers come to life,
and this is a painting by Sarah.
So Hank, before Sarah and I started dating, I actually bought that painting from her
and then months later,
when she came over to my apartment for the first time while we were dating, I was like,
"Look, I framed your beautiful painting!"
And she said, "Yeah,
That's upside-down."
Sometimes people ask me for romantic advice,
my advice?
Hang your future girlfriend's painting right-side up, for God's sakes.
I also keep all my foreign editions of The Fault In Our Stars here like,
"Das Schicksal Ist Ein Mieser Verräter"
"Förr Eller Senare Exploderar Jag",
"Faen Ta Skjebnen",
"Tähtiin kirjoitettu virhe",
then of course, there's "Gwiazd Nasych Wina",
"Nos Étoiles Contraires"
(I actually took French.)
...And the ones I have no way of  even pretending to know how to attempt.
Also in my office,
we have Leonardo's Leonardo.
But most importantly, we have this beautiful view of the river, including
Canada Geese.
I used to say Canadian Geese, Hank.
But then Canadians informed me, politely,
that that is incorrect.
"Geese don't have a nationality!", they said. "Thank you for mentioning Canada."
Baby ducks, baby ducks, baby ducks,
duckieeees!
Then we go down the hall and we have the kitchen,
featuring artwork by my lovely son, Henry Green,
as well as posters available now at <dftba.com>
We have to keep all the clif bars in here because mice.
Here is the tiger who does all the dishes.
Thanks tiger!
This is apparently the jar where we keep all the action figures,
you know so they don't get out and wreak havoc.
This is the room where we shoot Mental Floss where Stan and Mark also work?
There's the mental floss set.
Mark's the producer and director of the Mental Floss channel, say hi, Mark.
[Mark]: Hi, Mark.
And Stan, of course, is working on Crash Course as he always is.
[Stan]: Hi.
[Stan]: Stan.
Since this is an episode of Cribs, I got to show you what's in our fridge.
Mostly soda
and some beer
and apples!
Good job everybody.
Also, Hank, I have a theory that you'll find mustard in any refrigerator
and sure enough, even though we have nothing to mustard,
mustard.
So Hank, I wanted you to see the office
because 1) you've showed me yours
and 2) I wanted you to be able to meet
all of the nice people who actually make Crash Course and Mental Floss and the Swoodilypoopers happen.
This is particularly important because soon
I will be on Paternity leave.
But the things that we make here will continue to be made, even though I will not be in the office.
By the way I just noticed th- I- the pizza- me- red- why- hmm- yeah?
I'm gonna go down here by the thing that isn't a mustache.
So Hank, the Yeti's due to have a baby on June 1st
but it might happen earlier because you know that's- that's the way with babies.
So hopefully you'll see me next Tuesday,
but I will definitely see you on Friday.
DFTBA.